recent officer-involved shootings are
increasing the demand for police body
cameras but the cameras high price is
delaying those new programs in New
Jersey alone it would cost an estimated
eighty eight and a half million dollars
for the more than 35,000 officers in the
state to have one instead of buying new
cameras police in Jersey City will use
their cell phones and a Warner went to
Jersey City to find out how this
first-of-a-kind program will work good
morning officers here in Jersey City
tried traditional body cameras three
years ago but the mayor says the
software didn't work very well and the
data storage was expensive then he
learned about a much cheaper option
using something that's right in our
pockets when police officer Amir Ella
TKE prepares to go out on foot patrol he
straps on his gear which now includes a
body camera in a cell phone
anytime I have a community interaction
the camera will be news the police
issued cell phone is set to a mode that
only allows it to function as a cop
camera has everything the officer turns
the camera on and the recorded footage
streams directly to a secure server at
the police department Jersey City is the
first city in the u.s. to try this less
expensive method to record officers
actions I think we were early to the
conversation Steven Fulop is mayor we
started exploring a body cameras Google
mentioned that hey they may have a
solution
that they've worked with elsewhere in
the world would we be open to it and we
said yeah we'll take a look a sister
company to Google called jigsaw
developed the app called cop cast mayor
full of says the new system offers more
data storage options than traditional
body cams which also helps lower the
system's price by millions of dollars
not New York Chicago Jersey City so I
think Jersey City is a great place to
try innovative solutions to challenges
in government it's big enough that you
can actually see what happens and try
different things and it's small enough
that if it doesn't work you can change
and adapt the unit 10 amounting
Jersey City plans to roll out the
cellphone cameras to all of its 932
officers in the fall which is his way
that is heavy stole my camera roll the
system isn't perfect the department
wants to make the cameras less bulky and
lighter weight an officer Ella T who
helped test them admits not all
residents like to be recorded there are
situations where their service to calls
and people kind of don't want the police
there will come in and we have the
cameras on they kind of get camera shy
and they don't want to deal with mayor
full obsesses get used to it he foresees
a day when those phone cams might be
worn by every Jersey City government
employee who deals with the public the
quality of the service from our
employees are gonna be top-notch and I
think that if anything slips there's
gonna be a chance to review that and
correct it is it a little big
brother-ish I think ultimately our goal
is to deliver the best quality service
possible ACLU privacy advocate J Stanley
says that may be taking things a bit too
far last time I checked there haven't
been any housing inspectors who shot
unarmed black men there's no reason to
have the privacy problems that come with
these cameras for government employees
who don't have that power that police
officer has to shoot and kill when
you're in a world of terrorists risks
and security risks that these sort of
the tools are important it's just a
reality of where we are today so do I
think that some people are gonna say
this is like Big Brother yes so I think
that ultimately this is where we end up
from a technology standpoint for all
police departments yes as well for now
the cameras are staying within the
police department and the department
says it'll be focused on looking at
recorded video after any incidents but
supervisors do have the capability to
livestream this video and monitor it as
it happens and the department isn't
ruling out the possibility of using that
capability
eventually all right thank you Anna well
it's an interesting question for now it
seems the pros seemed outweigh the cons
we'll see mayor flub seems to like it in
Jersey City see how it plays out yeah I
could picture a day when we all have
cameras I'm thinking that too sometimes
you'd like a camera too thank you Anna